come on come on go get us one Lou get
us one yeah let's go win this come
on let's go here we go move I'm already
breathing hard boys go go go get him the
new season is underway let's go black come
on now yeah baby wake up let's go we got
to take that next step we got to take
it this year yeah we're not done yeah
yeah yes you guys had three lines
shut up we've talked about it all
training camp let's start the
climb tonight fellas it starts
tonight 33 34 61 61 looks weird you don't like
Louis number like that 61 was that what he wore
when he first came here I think that's what he
wore when he first came here H we'll have that
meeting with the coaches tomorrow going go
over every possible scenario roster wise the
big decision it's going to be either 13 Fords
60 12 Fords 70 uh Spence they just felt had a
strong Camp so far I thought Spence has been good
like we saw a little bit last year when they get
limited time up like he'll step in the lineup
and hop on a power play or his touches there's
no there's no acclim period he looks comfortable
where it'll get tricky with us is is we're going
to have to wave a good goalie cuz it's going to
be hard for us to carry three goalies for very
long cople will play Thursday we fly Thursday
day of the game to Salt Lake training camp for
the Los Angeles Kings is nearing its end and
today the team is headed to Salt Lake City
to play the San Jose Sharks in the League's
annual Frozen Fury Series held here in Utah
annually the game will be a homecoming for
Trevor Lewis the NHL's only active player
from the state Trevor being back here in Utah
playing your hometown being back with the Kings
how special is that yeah it's awesome I mean you
know there's coming back with the Kings and and
being around the guys in the city again it's
it's been unbelievable and then obviously they
get a chance to play here in front of family and
friends it's pretty special he Ralphie where is
he standing on the railing oh yeah he's run
out old school 61 Derby two preseason games
left for the Kings before the regular season
starts next Wednesday at home mik come on
[Applause] D Kings have been a playoff team
the last couple of years that being said the
expectations are a little higher this year get up
get up get up all the pieces back on that the goal
tending situation I think that's a concern that's
a question mark experience back there but maybe
maybe something to prove now a turnover in front
and a chance Copley with the sa cop Leo Lou grny
coming out of this hey I feel young [Applause]
Wes so Lake City native Trevor Lewis Lewis in
his second Tour of Duty with the Kings wearing
the A tonight as the alternate captain Oh Boy Lou
way to catch him Louie car grundstrom back for
Lewis Lewis inand you got out get b l nice vog
Lou hey hey 8 minutes in the Kings open
the scoring scores PL du from Kevin F
we go and from there the battle on the
ice intensifies this Pacific Division
rivalry heating up and it's not the regular
season yet I just hit him right right in a
chest the game goes back and forth before
heading to overtime tied at three and there
the Kings look to find their way to a
victory everybody be ready to go here
just rolling them out Hopey juice he'll start
and the Kings with possession hey we can bring
pucks back stay ahead of them in a change here
take the puck out if you have to into the Zone
Cuts in the middle hands it off to dowy right
side Cycles it Kee moves in shoots and scores
there's some more juice for you to win the
game Adrien Kee and OT [Applause] [Music]
you played with Trevor Lewis his first
time here is it cool to see a guy like
that get this moment get to wear the egg get
to play in front of friends and family yeah
for sure and I think it's uh you know it's
uh he's probably really excited to be here
and I would too if it was uh you know
my home time you come you have so many
family [Music] [Applause] friends [Music]
you w a shark King Sur Happ life thank
you playing back in my hometown in Salt
Lake don't get a chance to to play in
front of family and friends and I looked up
and warm up so my spotted my dad right away
he was wearing an old school 61 Louis Jersey I
don't know where he found it look at you looking
like a find that Jersey this is your rookie
Jersey where did you dig that out of in my
closet thank [Music] you it was a special special
night and I'm glad we got the win too so that was
awesome
bye Vegas Golden Nights here this afternoon
obviously defending Stanley Cup champions they
won the division last year the kings were third
these are two teams that figure to be at or near
the top again Saturday marks the king's final
preseason game a last chance to tune up before
the matchups count are you ready and are we ready
and the answer um I believe is yes fala buries it
du to fala we hope we hear that a lot during
the season we started the night while we got
sloppy we took some unwarranted penalties we
just didn't get it done tonight that will do
it it's a 7 to four win for the Golden Nights
through most of the preseason the kings were
solid they were on top of things they get the
results they want today's game a little bit of
a different story where concerns start to pop up
the camp has been odd there's no doubt about it
the relief is that knock on wood we came out
of this healthy everybody's looking forward
to Monday morning and then from there on it's
it's game on after the game the AR lights stay
on for the LA Kings Festival an event that
gives season ticket holders the chance to
meet players up close exhilarating for all
though also a bit intimidating for some oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah okay Pi he's so
nervous don't be nervous how's your day going
good how's yours good good oh look at you with a
little silver and I forgot to pull M out oh Sor
no all good here you go you want a picture
welcome to LA we're excited to have you you
go sounds stupid when I watch the games I'm always
looking no that's awesome thank you the mood may
be bright in the arena but in the front office
the time has arrived to make some final roster
decisions for opening night um goalies we're
going to split we're going to split the first
two games get them both up and running I think
it's important that both of them get a chance
real early they've both been really good and
uh they're both important we're going to need
them all you talk to both of them they know that
scenario they're going back each one's playing
a game this week they're fine we uh we talked to
TBS he could have a a 60 safe shut out but we're
committing to uh to coper the next night and uh
again it's the sum of our parts that's how we're
going to get it done yep so you're going to have
11 forwards and we'll have to go with 6D just with
the flexibility we're not able to have another
player up Spenny doesn't need waivers so he's
the one that will go down the com ation with
him was was pretty good I said listen if we
were doing our 12 and S you're in that mix after
your camp this year he understands he that he he
knows he's had a real good camp and he's made our
team but it's just it's out of his control cuz if
we had our way I think he obviously be in but
we don't have our way so it's the way it goes
I am disappointed in a way just because during
this training camp I think I showcase well and
in a way I think maybe I could be on the roster
but you know I just want to keep performing in
Ontario and if I keep uh playing well then
uh eventually I'll get called up and have
my opportunity again while Jordan Spence won't
be on the opening night roster and will have to
wait for his next opportunity it sounds like cam
Talbot and Phoenix Copley will each be getting
theirs in short order yes talot has been given the
start for opening night though with Copley right
behind him there's a sense the club could have a
truly formidable pair between the pipes this team
is ready to win now you can't get that rebound
so I think whoever is you know hot is going to
be able to play so if copper gets hot and and
he takes it and runs with it then that's good
for the team if I take and run with it that's
good for the team as well but if you get both
guys going and you can feel confident playing
either guy any given night I mean that's good
for everyone as well yeah we'll clean that
up get vocal copper yep you got it in four
thank
you there's a distinctive
sense of anticipation that
always accompanies the first
day of a new season in any
sport with ice hockey it's
as much the sounds as the
sights and from The Arena floor to the dressing
room all of it traces is a familiar sequence
of tasks and rituals for a team's entire
support staff that play out long before puck
drop a tribute to the significance of every last
millimeter a pursuit of perfection pleasing to the
eye everything needs to be completed
just so an acknowledgement of the
importance of every Last Detail all to
establish a foundation of order for the
long climb [Music] ahead the Devotion to
distinctiveness extends to all kinds of
pregame preparations which for veteran
Philip do know includes his sartorial
selections what's up boys what's up good
man yes what we got man yeah right let's go
nice nice nice sick had too oh my God crazy see
can nice the Final Touch that's sick with brown
shoes sneaker I think you no maybe look like
this oh yeah yeah yeah perfect like that with a
flipflop
nice double breast so yeah I like it
yeah we look yeah always like green uh
we have Adelia Rose and Philip Edward who's your
favorite hockey team G he just started playing
hockey my
girl
that's it and in your inside the finish up yeah
look good play good that's true the club that
dresses together plays Better Together okay
a theory that Den know as alternate Captain
appears to subscribe to as a way to integrate
newcomers like Pierre Luke DUIs onto the team
I me was my eighth eth NHL Camp I think and it's
been very different the whole coaching staff the
players everybody's been extremely helpful and
a lot of opportunities to get to know the guys
uh whether it being in austral or even here
it's been pretty crazy but it's been really
fun now I feel like I'm I'm part of the team
coming to you live from downtown LA tonight
is game number one of the 2023 24 season for
your LA Kings you get a little nervous you have
to see it as just another game two points now
is the same as the two points in in March but
at the same same time first game of the season at
home in front of our fans you know it's it's it's
special to go through training camp but then
to finally get to opening night it's always
very exciting you know it's the moment that
you've been waiting for and then you want to
see your team how they jel together during camp
and let's get going building's going to be loud
the building is going to be buzzing lots of
excitement obviously you know you still get a
little Jitters before before the first game
every year which which is a good thing but
uh it's now the the real thing starts and uh you
know real hockey Begins the coaching staff we're
excited about what are we going to bring to to
the ice surface are we are we going to play on
our toes are we going to get after a real good
team to come into the Year healthy and ready to
go that's exciting but at some point you got to
leave your mark on the game and you got to take
this team and and move it forward we have quality
people that are ready to go and the one thing I
know at this time of the year everybody's begging
for more ice time so there it is it's right in
front of you do something with [Music] it it's
opening night as the LA Kings play host to the
Colorado Avalanche a full house is expected
18,000 plus as the Kings embark on their 57th
NHL season uh quickly for us we've talked about
it all training camp a lot faster get it going
somewhere and let's get moving and let's start
the climb tonight fellas you're ready it going
to be a tough road we all know that but it starts
tonight help each other pull on the Rope uphill so
let's go let's go win this come on come on let's
go come on come on come let's go let's go let's
go after a 3we camp that included the longest
road Tri trip in NHL history the real thing is
at last here the first of 82 and then hopefully
more the beginning of a climb where the goal is
absolute a Stanley Cup for the Los Angeles Kings
star power for both these teams and all of them
on the ice to start the game here tonight
we've been through it enough we know what to
do all right let's do
this com black let's go here let's
go go go go go go let's be direct early here
hey direct early shoot the puck early fellas
there you go got his first shot on that picked up
by fala who wrapped it around on the rebound try
to the center Shot by duah goes over top of the
net in his King's debut now we're buzzing boys
now we're buzzing get it there early got
him got to happen quicker fellas let's go
let's go me Allen top for dowy dowy risting it
that one Chang directions gorev able to adjust
knock it down and cover good read good read
good talk let's go tapes with Roy behind for
Ranon kicked it to his stick chipped to the
front McKinnon scores is all right come on
let's go it's all right and the ABS have
the first goal of this game one- nothing
SC back come on come on barrier on it again
centering Fe comes out F loads it up with a
shot that one knocked down may have hit the bar
ni boys let's go let's go buck still out in a
dangerous area and the shot came through from
anglet that's the way the first puan com to a
close okay good period penalty kill excellent
job well done below the goal line we're going
backward trying to make the right play
but everybody's slow it's happening in
slow motion when we got it behind and we went
on the four check we had good opportunities in
the ozone despite pressure by the Kings
Colorado adds a second goal early in the
second and then quickly looks to add to
their lead from there I got him I got and
scores back to work come on lots of night lots of
night a three nothing lead for Colorado that'll
get one got to get one boys come on start with
one a lot of hockey boys lot of hockey let's
go no no get up Johnson has to hurry up he get
to that puck for Grunst wiping out was Manson
so was Johnson they [Applause] score Carl Grunst
gets the King's first goal of the new season the
Avalanche lead is now three to one let's get him
let's get him Fier hope free by Taves and trying
to slip through as frerick olon and a penalty
coming and D McMan who has thrown the gloves
off trying to get after him here we got there's o
and lafier in his NHL debut as o Conor pulled the
rookie out of the pile they're having a pretty
good count the family loves it welcome to the
National Hockey League alfier that boy left that
Bo left good job kid got to get one before we go
in boys yep come on let's get it in and on the
net and see if we can get a face off in there
hey with 10 point 8 on the clock right it boy off
the draw the Kings bouncing it on gold bouncing
Puck you get knocked it [Applause] down yeah I my
tee kopar flipped it in on goal it went off the
goenda your helmet and and with 4.6 seconds left
in the second period the kings
are to within a goal where my
team and that changes the entire complexion of
the hockey game on one [Applause] bounce that
momentum though proves difficult to sustain
and it's the Avalanche who end up doing the
only scoring of the final period to take the win
on opening night in La that'll do it last year's
Central Division Champions come into La here
on opening night and defeat the Kings 5 [Music]
to2 just as distinctive as the
anticipation that always accompanies
the start of a new season is the hollow
that follows when game one results in a
loss it sits in the air long after the Arena
empties trailing the tasks and rituals that
serve as the postcript to the action what happens
at the beginning of the year is you're happy or
the world is crashing down on you but that's
just part of an 82 game schedule there's a
long road ahead and that's exciting of course
you don't like to lose but they feel they got a
really good team it's a hockey game there's 82
of them in the season just take a deep breath
the truth is one game is hardly enough to cut
down the hope that everything that came before
produced the being of Camp is always exciting
this year the expectation are much greater on
our team to an outsider training camp might
seem like a collection of obligations we got
to take that next step we got to take it this
year a game plan a team has to install we have
talked about finishing the clim position battles
that have to be waged roster spots that have to
be determined let's get going today you got jobs
to do trips sometimes unfathomably long they all
have to take we're trying to promote the game
worldwide you have a favorite team from now
[Music]
on
yeah but the most successful teams
always find ways to make the best
of every part of the process to
strengthen bonds fortify goals
and establish a collective identity that
will carry them through the next several
months so much is inevitably out of
their control weol but amid the wind
wins and losses and ups and downs the
idea is that everything they've already
built oh Big D will be what defines a long
Unforgettable climb all the way to the top
is that climb the top of the mountain we all
hope [Music] so for more inside access to the
king's training camp go to NHL network.com
or follow #b theeg glass on social media